hi everyone I'm Milano Achara Lanza and
welcome to my channel today you guys are
watching a video where I interview some
pro race drivers and talk to the guys
who made forza 5 @ eb expo 2013 so that
was like October last year but I still
think it's really really cool to hear
what actual Pro race drivers have to say
about the game but I do also have some
compacts to give away so if you guys
want to win some of those stay tuned
until the end to find out how hopefully
you guys enjoy the video I just finished
playing force of 5 it looks so shiny so
sleek everything's definitely been
redone let's go check out what everyone
else think my name is Brian Ekberg I'm
the community manager with turn 10
studios and we're the makers of Forza
Motorsport 5 I'm John Wendel I'm the
content director for turn 10 so what is
new in Forza 5 well the biggest thing
with forts of 5 is obviously it's on the
Xbox one it's an exclusive title for the
launch so it's on the new hardware which
is great we have an all new graphics
engine that emphasizes light atmosphere
and physically based materials that
we've applied to all new content all
cars all tracks have been reauthorized
one at this new graphics engine running
at 1080p 60 frames a second the big
announcement recently was the inclusion
of Bathurst for the first time it is I
think our most highly requested track
Bathurst is an incredibly complex
circuit has elevation change and really
subtle camber change up through the
esses at the top of Mount Panorama we
went out to the track we spent three
days they're completely digitally laser
scanned the entire facility to get it to
that level of details
I'm here with Matthias and Andy has just
the amazing history obviously for a race
driver it's a mega lot with great
section in the middle over the mountain
the fans are fantastic the Racing's
always brilliant at the end there's such
a close race after six hours of running
and have you had a chance to play the
track on the new Forza 5 absolutely yeah
I couldn't wait to get on it to be
honest the guys have really done a great
job they've been around the track
lasered it accuracy and detail is just
second to none I'm here with Australian
motorsport racing legend Marc scape here
today what did you think of force of 5
how do you feel about the realism the
realism is unbelievable I actually
thought the graphics were photos that's
how good it was and then I was
explaining to Matias Eckstrom who hasn't
been to Bathurst before
some of the road irregularities the
cambers and that's all there
Oh seriously I was just I was gobsmacked
so you think you could accurately teach
someone to prepare for Bathurst using
four to five a 100% so that's it for the
expo but here is how you can win stuff
xbox were nice enough to give me ten
codes for car packs but I can't just
give them away that would be way too
easy so instead I want you guys to tell
me in the comments below what is your
favorite car and why I will be picking
the comments that stick out to me the
most and I will message the winners on
youtube so make sure that you check your
messages and the competition closes on
at the 15th of February so make sure
that you get your answers in sooo big
thanks to everyone at Xbox Australia and
I will see you guys next time bye also
side note I have tonsillitis so I'm
sorry that I sound so ridiculous right
now don't judge me